tengo cáncer
hoy donde exprimir a la verdad es que
dije cuando me vio dormida
vi la expresión de mis médicos y lo
dedujo
esta no es una forma muy usual de
enterarte que tienes un cáncer y que
tienes una enfermedad tan grave
cómo empezó esto hace 7 años me encontré
con mi médico quien me recomendó que me
hiciera una colonoscopia preventivamente
yo me sentía sana
pero tenía cierta resistencia a este
tipo de exámenes
pensaba que maluco que le hagan a un
examen de éstos
y finalmente cede y me dice el bendito
examen
pero tuve la fortuna y el privilegio de
encontrar este pequeño tumor
pensarán ustedes afortunada privilegiada
sí porque ese pequeño tumor un tumor
incipiente que no había producido
síntomas no se encontraron metástasis ni
nada que atentara contra mi vida
pero mi vida como profesional de la
salud cambió
cambio porque no pude seguir elaborando
ni cuidando a mi esposo que tiene una
esclerosis múltiple profesional de la
salud también
así de cuidar a ser cuidada
de profesional de la salud a ser
paciente
y en ese capítulo de mi vida como
paciente viví todas las emociones de una
persona que sufre de cáncer o de
cualquier enfermedad tan grave
más que el miedo a morir sentía miedo al
dolor tenía susto y tenía nervios de lo
que pudiera ocasionar las quimioterapias
en mí
sentía mucho temor a la incertidumbre
pero la incertidumbre tiene una cura y
es la esperanza y me aferré a la
esperanza de que todo iba a salir bien y
todo salió bien
en estos escenarios como paciente
también encontré otras situaciones menos
afortunadas en otros procesos de otros
pacientes por primera vez me senté en
una sala a esperar que un funcionario me
autorizar a un procedimiento un
tratamiento
y vería como en una sala parte
muchas personas estaban desde la
madrugada esperando que les autorizaran
este mismo papel
y entonces vienen los cuestionamientos
empiezo a esculcar en mi mente tanto los
conocimientos de promoción y prevención
mi especialidad teórica y vivencial
y recuerdo tantas frases bonitas que
muchos funcionarios de salud como quizás
hay muchos en este auditorio expresaron
cuando visionaron la salud de una manera
diferente
de cuerpo
la frase de la organización mundial de
la salud hace muchos años salud para
todos en el año 2000
y me preguntó
hemos avanzado
me lo pregunto cuando otros pacientes me
comentan el doctor me dijo que ya no
había nada que hacer
el doctor me dijo que si yo sabía que mi
tratamiento era muy costoso
me negaron el medicamento
el doctor ni siquiera me miró
sé que eso es en algunos profesionales
hay muchos que son
profesionales de mucha calidad
pero esas palabras sumadas a un
diagnóstico desesperanzador ocasionan en
una persona un impacto emocional tan
grave o más que la misma enfermedad
y ahí viene
como paciente que podría ser yo
para mejorar ese sistema
desde esa pregunta cuánto hemos avanzado
encontré el ministerio de salud de
colombia dice que el índice de
mortalidad ha bajado pero la
discapacidad ha aumentado y aumenta a
veces por esos diagnósticos retrasados
por diagnósticos cerrados por
tratamientos que no se inician a tiempo
por la violencia en nuestro país es una
situación pues que también produce
discapacidad pero a veces también es
porque el paciente no realiza bien sus
tratamientos
y no se ha preguntado qué es lo más
conveniente para cada uno
durante este proceso de salud
me encontré que había otro tumor más
grave que si había ocasionado metástasis
es el cáncer de la deshumanización del
sistema de salud
y así como paciente yo vi cuando enfermo
está el sistema de salud
todos somos responsables de este sistema
de salud los profesionales de salud los
funcionarios de gobierno
las universidades las empresas
farmacéuticas y nosotros como pacientes
todos somos responsables deben ser
barreras como son la arrogancia de
algunos profesionales de salud que no
empatiza con sus pacientes los intereses
económicos ante puestos al bienestar y
al sufrimiento ajeno
y la actitud pasiva o reactiva de los
pacientes
y aquí empecé a pensar cómo se mejoraría
un sistema de salud
y más que técnicamente yo proponer
estrategias
pienso que es desde lo básico
todos somos responsables entonces de
crear una armonía que por medio de
valores como la solidaridad la humanidad
la proactividad
el respeto y principalmente la
honestidad podamos generar un buen
sistema de salud que conduzca a la
transformación de un a una sociedad más
sana y equitativa
aquí
empecé a ocupar yo
esos espacios que la vida me proporcionó
con las secuelas de tratar mi cáncer e
ingresé como voluntaria a una asociación
de pacientes de una enfermedad diferente
de la que yo tenía
que también estaban buscando esa mejor
calidad y oportuna atención en salud
asignación práctica médica solidaria
práctica médica solidaria es un espacio
donde profesionales de salud y pacientes
reunidos durante un día
reciben los conocimientos de su médico
un espacio donde más allá de la consulta
y ese escaso tiempo que se puede brindar
todos aprenden y enseñan unos de otros
el médico entrega sus conocimientos en
un lenguaje sencillo que tanto
profesionales como pacientes entiendan
aún en presentaciones muy científicas
aprende a solidarizarse con ese paciente
dándoles esperanza y vida y el paciente
ahí ve la humanidad de sus médicos
el paciente aprende a ser un paciente
más proactivo porque fue la proactividad
de lo que hizo que yo encontrara mi
cáncer a tiempo
también vemos que la rehabilitación
es prevención también prevención de una
mayor discapacidad porque todos tenemos
que tratar de combatir esa mayor
discapacidad principalmente desde la
visión que laboralmente se tiene de una
persona con una capacidad diferente
también encontramos que en este
mejoramiento de la relación
médico-paciente los pacientes empezaron
a expresarse mejor de sus médicos y hubo
una relación y una comunicación también
buena que pienso que puede ser una
oportunidad para transformar ese sistema
de salud por último vemos
la psicología de los pacientes cambio de
ser un paciente agresivo reactivo a
buscar eso es más tratamientos y todo lo
necesario para su cuidado de salud que
puede brindarle el médico
la promoción y la prevención
es un proceso costoso y que está todavía
muy demorado en nuestro país pero pienso
que más que beneficioso para el sistema
es un beneficio para el mismo paciente
porque fue la forma como yo traté mi
cáncer y lo hice a tiempo
este mensaje
la pendiente a que a través de esa
armonía y esos valores construyamos un
sistema de salud de calidad que
contribuya a mejorar en la salud en este
país es para que todos asumamos nuestro
rol en la vida y con compromiso
trabajemos por un mejor estado
gracias
[Aplausos]